hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Teen Wolf episode 11 video
since the finales next week after we get
through all the craziness of this week
I'll explain what's going on with season
5 right now there are a number of ways
the finale can still go down so I'll add
my favorite theories after my review
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet but here are my
top 5 WTF moments I'll wait just a sec
okay here we go number 5 dicen is back
Seth Gilliam has been filming Walking
Dead Season 5 that's why he hasn't been
in very many episodes this season
people die way more frequently on that
show so the odds that he'd totally bail
on Teen Wolf like he'd lead the show are
pretty slim like I think he'll
definitely be back in season 5 Daniel
Sharman is a good example that when he
left the show he asked specifically not
to be killed off so that he could always
come back if he wanted to but I totally
loved The Silence of the Lambs thing
going on between dr. VALIC and Deaton
I'm gonna go ahead and guess he was not
a medical doctor though so if he didn't
get the trepanation reference trepang
was basically the old process of
drilling a hole in someone's head to
release pressure they would do that to
expose you know some of the outer brain
matter just as a way to fix medical
problems there's actually evidence that
they practice it all the way back and
the Neolithic era that was around like
10,000 BC way a long time ago that was
the time that ageing humans started to
develop more sophisticated tools
apparently so that they could drill
holes in each other's heads but Teen
Wolf history lessons for the win I guess
the reason that bollock did it was just
to expose that third eye whenever he
manifested psionic powers and if you
didn't notice the place where Deaton
went in the dream state was that same
underground temple in Mexico where Kate
was hiding out or where she's been
hiding out and where they found Derek in
the season premiere Teen Wolf is all
about the circle alive so they started
in Mexico they have to travel around and
come back to Mexico at the end they
haven't fully explained Kate's magic yet
so I'm hoping the finale which is
actually titled the broken spell clear
some of that up like hopefully Deaton
will explain the mechanics of what Kate
has done the other big reveal though is
the promise that Deaton made to someone
he loved I'm assuming that's Derek's
mother
hopefully season five is gonna explain
that that's like a whole episode you
could spend on that but on to number
four Derek does not care about the money
mostly because it was never his it's all
Peter's like Stiles thought which is
kind of funny Derek's money for all
intents and purposes
has always been safe he owns the loft
and the rest is just in a series of bank
accounts
I think that's the show just telling us
that his money is safe like there's no
danger to Derek's money
it sounded like Derek was suggesting
that Scott keep the money I mean he was
saying that he didn't want Peter to get
it back or didn't think it was a good
idea but I think he was implying that
Scott should just take it back home but
don't you wonder about Stiles and that I
can house debt now like maybe it wasn't
forgiven maybe Scott paid it off and
manufactured the letter to Stiles that
unless Stiles was faking and he wrote
the letter to his dad either way I don't
think the Peter is gonna get his money
back regardless of how that debt got
paid off there was also a moment when
Derek was explaining that he owned the
building but I thought the show was
trying to tease Scott moving into the
loft just to fix his money problems like
we don't need to fix our roof because we
live in Derek's building rent-free now I
don't think that's actually gonna happen
I think Scott and Kira having the date
in the loft was about as far as that'll
go but on to number three Liam is still
totally flipping out it's pretty clear
they're preparing him for a big
turnaround in the finale the full moon
is a problem because he still can't
control his shifts and it's only 24
hours away that's basically the show
telling us that the finale will be a
full moon so everyone's gonna be totally
crazy but they'll be super powered I am
totally gonna be happy to see Liam get
out of that headspace see him stop
hallucinating stuff that's been going
about all season it's one of the few
running stories that I haven't enjoyed
as much but I do understand that he's
like the new guy so he has to have a
struggle to overcome across the season
he's the freshman so he gets the scared
puppy problems in the finale presumably
he'll overcome those earn his wolf
stripes and just become a full-fledged
member of the pack usually surviving
traumatic events is what brings people
together which of course Kate and Peter
are more than happy to supply there was
this whole thing going across the entire
episode reminding us about the
relationship between fear anger and
strength and I think that's gonna come
back in the finale
Liam going all bro dude in the weight
room was just a good reminder that the
more angry is the stronger he gets like
a sliding scale of Hulk Ness I'm just
betting in the finale he'll find that
motivation to stay pissed off enough to
destroy the berserkers Scott's always
gonna be the most powerful one just
because of his alpha abilities but Liam
has been teased as being like crazy more
powerful than any of the other wolves I
was really happy to see Brett help him
out during
lacrosse game there's also a chance that
Brett could help out in the finale -
especially if Satomi gets involved we
don't really know who they're taking
down to Mexico but presumably everyone
is going but on to number two things
getting a little bit more serious now
Peter wants Malia to kill Kate this
actually got me really excited at the
thought that she would go through with
it not because she wants to help Peter
but because she'll have to save Scott
they've already established how
protective of Scott she is and she's not
fully integrated into human society like
she's still got a lot of animal in her
personality so here - why she's still in
kind of a limbo state so she could be in
that mind space where she considers
killing Kate to be a totally justifiable
act she can even feel happy about it
like she's saving them we're not the
only thing that made it sound kind of
sinister was Peter giving off his Creepo
vibe and who else loved his reaction to
the desert wolf
I am positive she's your mother I cannot
wait to learn about that history I'm not
totally sure we'll meet her in the
finale but hopefully by season five
she'll be a character on the show but
I'm really hoping to see is Malia go
through with killing Kate in the finale
and it just racks her with guilt for all
of season five and it takes her mother
to help her get over it
let the remorse for killing Kate will be
more than Stiles can help her with it'll
be something she needs her mother for I
can already imagine their awkward family
dinners
Peter the desert wolf and Malia I wonder
if something like that came up Derek
would just pretend to have a date with
Braden just go off and hide somewhere
but my number one WTF moment kate is
going to turn scott into a berserker or
maybe I should say turn him into
something that looks like a berserker
it's still so unclear what's involved
with that
I'm guessing Deaton is gonna explain
that part he's gonna Deaton splain
berserkers and we have to remember what
Derek looked like when he kind of went
it's a semi alpha form in episode 10
like I think that we'll see that full-on
in the finale hopefully we'll get to see
him Hulk out Peter Alpha style just
smashed the hell out of the temple
presumably Deaton knows what's happened
to Derek - so I'm guessing that saving
Scott fixing Derek and Liam fixing
himself will all tie in with Malia
killing Kate I don't think it's gonna be
that simple like killing Kate isn't just
gonna fix everything but I do think that
the berserkers have something to do with
Derek's mojo like I'm wondering if Kate
is using his mojo to power the
transformations
Scott's arc this season has been all
about him dancing around the idea of
becoming a
stir him hallucinating killing Liam in
his dream State actually makes a lot
more sense now
that might have been a premonition for
whatever Kobe like under Kate's
influence the interesting thing about
the way the end of the episode though
and what they were teasing for the
finale is is that if Peters gonna try
and steal Scott's powers I think the
circumstances of Scott's death are
really important for how that works
I mean if Scott's friends end up killing
him like Kate wants I think that would
totally botched Peters plan I think
Peter has to be the one to kill Scott to
take his power which might be why Peter
is enlisting Malia's help just as a
backup anyway let me know what your
biggest WTF moment from the episode was
and do you think the Kade is actually
gonna turn Scott or is he gonna like
Hulk out at the last moment and it's
like a total fake out like he won't
actually become a berserker he'll just
go into crazy alpha form so here
actually a couple of my bigger
predictions first I don't think that
Peter is gonna take Scott's power but he
will steal someone's power Malia might
not end up killing Kate but she will do
something to completely mentally scar
herself that will last through season
five and Scott is gonna go into a full
alpha form he'll look like a virgin of
whatever Peter looked like super huge
but not quite the same and we will see
Parrish finally manifest his powers I
know I didn't mention it during my top
five moments but we did see parish's
eyes flash red so I think we'll figure
out whatever he actually is and I'm
guessing it's fire related the title of
the finale like I said is broken spell
so it implies that they'll break the
spell Cait put on Derek so whatever is
happening he'll be fixed by season five
so overall I gave the episode a solid
b-plus I thought it was a good setup for
the finale and the way they tease things
and character arts that'll go into
season five I did like the really trashy
romance novel motif they went for it too
although that only kind of went up to
about halfway through the episode
speaking of which I tried to read the
titles of all those books that dr. VALIC
had I only saw the afternoon wife loves
passion and Hawaiian honeymoon maybe
there's a teaser in there for season
five like between the finale and season
five some of the characters are go on
vacation to Hawaii but the afternoon
wife could totally be a reference to
Malia's mother but I guess you could
also see them as visual references to
all the trashy romance and novel moments
in the episode like when it jumped from
couple to couple like you know we had
Derek and Braden then we had Stiles and
Malia and then Scott and Kira the books
could just be representative of them I
totally could see Braden taking Derek to
Hawaii
in the offseason though that would be a
lot of fun so you guys can let me know
if you agree but I feel like season 4
has done a good job of setting each of
these characters up so that they have a
place to go in future seasons like not
just season five like but they'll have
places to develop themselves into season
seven I don't see the show going past
seven seasons but if they can gain the
type of audience the supernatural has
they could go on forever especially if
they can keep bringing new characters
like Liam in don't you just feel like
Dylan Sprayberry could totally be like
the new Scott if Tyler Posey wanted to
leave the show and like they had Scott
leave town for a while or something
that's actually good thought to end on
how many seasons do you think the team
will forget I expect well at least sees
six
they wouldn't have upped the order from
twelve to twenty between seasons four
and five of MTV did not feel confident
about the show but since I'm pretty much
moved into my new apartment even though
I don't quite have my set fixed yet
that's why it looks like I'm making
videos in limbo I will be posting my
team will finale video on time so
that'll be Monday night be sure to
subscribe to get it if you're just
finding me for the first time right now
though you can click here to get last
week's episode video and you can click
here to start getting ready for arrow in
the flash some [ __ ] is gonna be going
down those shows are actually starting
in October so thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight high
fives